تجدد القتال في الخرطوم بين قوات الجيش
وقوات الدعم السريع بعد هدنه 24 ساعه
راهنت على وقف الاقتتال وفسح المجال
المدنيين ليتدبروا حاجاتهم المعيشيه
يتزامن ذلك مع قمه ثلاثيه مصغره في جيبوتي
بين رؤساء الدول المضيفه ودوله جنوب
السودان وكينيا وممثل عن ايجاد للبحث في
سبل تنفيذ توصيات قاده المنظمه لانهاء
النزاع
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم كان هذا خبر حلقتنا ولنا في
نقاشه ثلاثه مساراته ما ابرز تطورات
الميدانيه في السودان مع ارتفاع وتيره
الاشتباكات بين الجيش والدعم السريع في
العاصمه الخرطوم وفي انحاء مختلفه من
البلاد وما المبادرات الجديده المطروحه
وما حيثيات واجنده المباحثات الافريقيه في
جيبوتي والتي تتصدرها الازمه السودانيه
ما افاق وفرص نجاح المبادره الافريقيه
وغيرها في وقف القتال المحتدم ووضع حد
لنزيف الدم في السودان
[موسيقى]
قوس للتهدئه سرعان ما اغلق ليعود الاقتتال
مجددا بين قوات الجيش وقوات الدعم السريع
في السودان جوله جديده من العنف الدم
تتحدى الجهود الاقليميه والدوليه الراميه
لايقاف الحرب والعوده بالخلاف الى مربع
التفاوض بحثا عن الحلول السلميه وهو الهدف
الذي لاجله تعقد في جيبوتي قمه رئاسيه
ثلاثيه تحت مظله منظمه ايجاده يفترض بها
ان تقدم رؤيه المنظمه لحل الازمه
السودانيه الرئيس الكيني ويليام روتو وصف
الاوضاع في السودان بالسيئه والتي تزداد
تعقيدا ولاجل التوصل لحل قال الرئيس
الجيبوتي اسماعيل عمر جيلي قال ان دول
الايجاد ستدرس سبل اقناع طرفي الازمه في
السودان باجراء حوار كفيل بوقف اطلاق
النار بشكل فعلي هدف يرتكز بحسب المنظمه
الى توحيد الجهود القاريه الدوليه والى
الحد من التدخلات الخارجيه وايجاد حل
لازمه اللاجئين المتفاقمه بفعل استمرار
الاقتتال وتعول ايجاد على ان وسطتها ستطرح
ليتم اعتمادها من قبل قمه للمنظمه ومن
اليه ومن الاليه الموسعه التابعه للاتحاد
الافريقي وعن كل تلك الجهود يفترض ان
تنبثق اليه للمراقبه تشمل اضافه الى طرفي
القتال اطرافا مدنيه لتعمل تحت مظله قاريه
واقليميه تشارك فيها الجامعه العربيه
والامم المتحده
[موسيقى]
ينضم الينا من ام درمان احمد عمر خوجه
للكاتب والمحلل السياسي كما ينضم الينا من
اديس ابابا بروك هايلو استاذ العلوم
السياسيه والدراسات الافريقيه وسيضم الينا
من الخرطوم حافظ كبير الكاتب والمحلل
السياسي ابدا معك سيد احمد عمر خوجه لسيد
احمد من المفترض بالهدنه الاخيره ان تؤدي
الى اشاعه اجواء من الثقه وتحقق تهدئه الا
ان هذه التهدئه سرعان ما انتهت واجواء
الثقه لم تتحقق ما السبب في ذلك بتقديرك
بعيدا عن تبادل الاتهامات
التحول السريع بعد الهدنه ال 24 ساعه
واشتعال الامر من خلال اليوم
حقيقه 24 ساعه كانت يعني فتره ضيقه حتى
يعني تتركز الجهود بشكل وافر من اجل يعني
اعادتها وتطويلها لفتره اطول او بلوره
مشروع اتفاق سياسي
غير كافيه
احمد عقب الكود التي هذه ليست الهدنه
الاولى كانت هنالك هدى سابقه لها منها من
امتدا الى سبعه ايام
كانت تتكسر تحت حاجز انعدام الثقه
وعدم التزام عدم الالتزام
بالمواضيع الانسانيه التي من اجلها شرعت
هذه الهدى المختلفه
وتضرر المواطنين من خلال بقاء قوات في
المساكن واستمرار الانتخابات التي عانوا
منها كثيرا الانعدام الثقه وانعدام
التغيير بين الهدنه واللاهدنه هو الذي
اعجب بانفجار الاوضاع بعد هدنه ال 24 ساعه
القصيره النسبيا مقارنه بما وضع بما مضى
كيف تحول الى السيد حافظ كبير سيد حافظ
عندما نتحدث عن هدنه يكون الهدف منها هو
التهدئه وهذا ما تحقق لمده 24 ساعه ولكن
عاد القتال لي يتوسع
ويتكثف من جديد ما قيمه هذه الهدى وما هي
الاسباب التي تجعل من امكانيه تمديدها
ممكنه
من الواضحه بان السيد حافظ كبير غير جاهز
معنا الى حد الان اتحول الى سيد بروك
هايلو سيد بروك هايلو جهود افريقيه وجهود
من منظمه الايجاد ما هي الخلاصات التي
يمكن استنتاجها من كل الهدن السابقه
والبناء عليها من قبل منظمه الايجاد وايضا
الاتحاد الافريقي
بدايه شكرا على الاستضافه في الجزيره معكم
اليوم كمحلل
ما يحدث الان فان وقف اطلاق النار الذي
خلق اعتقد هو وقف اطلاق النار الثامن وهذا
امر محزن ويفطر الفؤاد ان نجد انفسنا وما
هذا الواقع اشعر ان المتحدث الاول كان
هنالك انعدام وقله في الثقه نعم اوافقه
الراي هو فقط لم يكن انعدام الثقه لكن
ايضا كان موضوض عدم وضع وضع السودان
والسودانيين الاولويه يبدو وكاننا طرفان
يقاتلان بعضهما البعض من اجل مصالحنا فقط
للسيطره على السلطه والبقاء فيها اذا ما
كانت تركيز فقط على ما يزعموا انهم يمثلوه
يمثلون انهم يزعمون انهم يمثلون الشعب
السوداني لكن ملايين السود
يجب ان يكونوا هم في مقدمه الاولويات
بالنسبه للايجاد يجب تشجيع مبادره السلام
التي ترعاها الايجاد وانا امل ايضا ان
ايجاد ستعمل من اجل تحقيق وقفا لاطلاق
النار وان تكون يكون هنالك تقويه ولجهود
التي تسعى لاحضار الطرفين زاويه الى
المفاوضات ولربما ان يكون هنالك شرح
للطرفين انه بمساعده الاتحاد الافريقي
والامم المتحده
وسيكون هنالك نوع من قوه لحفظ السلام
ستكون بين الفصائل المتقاتله اعتقد ان
الوقت ينفد وهذا هذه هي ربما هو الخيار
الوحيد الحقيقي هذه هذا هذه هي الطريقه
التي ارى فيها الامور
نتحول الى السيده حافظ كبير الذي انضم
الينا سيد حافظ كبير هذه الهدنه صمدت 24
ساعه ما الذي يحول اذا كانت الهدى قادره
على الصمود 24 ساعه ما الذي يمنع من ان
تصمت فتره اطول ما الذي يمنع من تمديددها
غير اتهام الطرف الاخر بانه هو من قام
بالاعتداء
يعني تحيه طيبه لكم ولضيوفك الكرام اذا
سمعت السؤال جيدا ان هدنه ال 24 ساعه تم
الالتزام بها بشكل جيد لكن هناك طرف يريد
الاستفاده من هذه الهدنه في تجهيز نفسه
عسكريا وتحقيق مكاسب وهذا ظهر جليا خلال
معارك اليوم في منطقه مناطق متعدده القوات
المسلحه يعني
حاولت بقدر ما تستطيع اليوم ان تحقق نصرا
عسكريا لكنها عجزت عن ذلك في منطقه بحري
وكذلك في منطقه الخرطوم وهذا ليس يعني
وانما يعني مده 24 ساعه هل هي كافيه
يعني وضع الخطط وتجهيز المعدات واعاده
التموضع كما تقول لكي يجهز الطرف الاخر
نفسه نحن نتحدث عن 24 ساعه فقط
الاخيره
وبالطبع حتى قبل الهدنه هناك تجهيزات تجري
واستفاد الجيش من الهدنه في انه حرك
الياته العسكريه بالقرب من مواقع الدعم
الثلاث في شرق النيل تحركت قوات من منطقه
حطاب وكذلك تحركت قوات من غرب كوبري
الحلفايه وكذلك تحركت القوات في الخرطوم
لكن هذا ليس الاهم الاهم في ان الاراده
غير متوفره وفي ان هناك طرف يحاول كسب
الوقت ويحاول الاستفاده قدر الامكان من
هذه الهدنه لتحقيق نصره عسكري وليس من
اجله زياده يعني من اجل حمايه حقوق
الانسان او حمايه المدنيين وكذلك من اجل
بناء الثقه لتمديد الهدنه او للتقدم نحو
الاخر لتوقيع وقف اطلاق النار الجيش حاول
اليوم لكنه فشل هذا الامر تكرر كثيرا في
معارك مختلفه ولم يستطيع تحقيق نصرا يعني
يخول له او يجعل من موقفه التفاضل قويا
وبالتالي يعني ثبت اكثر من مره ان هذه
العسك ريه كثيرا وبالتالي الافضل
لو سمحت لي سيد احمد جهود يقوم بها
الايجاد اليوم وهذه الجهود ستسفر عن اليه
او خارطه الطريق ستعتمدها يعتمدها الاتحاد
الافريقي كيف تنظرون الى هذه الجهود وما
هي فرص نجاحها
والله انا اعتقد ان جهود ايجاد ومن خلفها
الاتحاد الافريقي في جهود يعني مبشره
ويمكن ان
يؤتى منها الكثير من الاهداف التي تحاول
السيطره على هذه الحرب ذلك لان المبادره
التي قامت بها المملكه العربيه السعوديه
يعني هي بعيده عن واقع السوداني شيء بعيد
وهي يعني لم تراعي الواقع السوداني
والتعقيدات الموجوده الاقتصاديه والعسكريه
والقبليه والسياسيه هذه التعقيلات لم
تراعى كثيرا لذلك هي ساوت بين الطرفين
كانهم يعني طرفين متساويين متقاتلين لكن
الاتحاد الافريقي مسنود بدول الايجاده
التي هي اغرب
والسودان احد دول هذا الاقليم واغرب الى
روح العامه والى الواقع الموجود في
المتشابه في كثير من هذه الدول جنوب
السودان وكيليا واثيوبيا كلها يعني تعاني
من نفس الاشكالات التي يعاني منها السود
والتي لم تراعيها الهدنه التي غادتها
المملكه السعوديه
والولايات المتحده الامريكيه اعتقد ان
جهود الاتحاد الافريقي ستكون اكثر واقعيه
ستكون اعدل في النظر الى طبيعه الصراع في
السودان والى حقيقه الصراع والى المشاكل
التي جعلت من القوات المسلحه السودانيه
يعني تقوم بواجبها السياسي والاقتصادي
والامن والعسكري التي يعني اقرت في كثير
من هذه الدول نفسها في اثيوبيا اشرت الى
الى نقطه محدده وهي المساواه بين الجانبين
وهنا اتحول للسيد بروكهايل وسيد بروك يعني
حل الاتحاد الافريقي قادر على اخذ ومنظمه
ايجاد قادره على اخذ هذه النقطه بعين
الاعتبار ما الذي ممكن ان يجعل من مبادره
من قبل ايجاد تنجح بينما فشلت او الى حد
الان لم تحقق الوسطات الاخرى النتائج
المرجوه منها
[موسيقى]
هذا سؤال وجيه للغايه
اعتقد ان مبادره ايجاد ستكون فرصتها افضل
للنجاح لعده اسباب اولها واهمها انها تاتي
من دول الجوار هي لديها نفس الاوضاع
بالنسبه
السكانيه والانسانيه
والسودان وايضا والسودان وليبيا واوضاع
مشابهه ثانيا معظم دول الايجاد تاثرت بنوع
من انواع
عدم الاستقرار الاهليه او الحرب الاهليه
خلال العقود الماضيه جنوب السودان اثيوبيا
ودول اخرى كذلك بالتالي فان تلك الدول
جوار السودان اعتقد انها ملتزمه
بالمساهمه في ان يكون لها دور تلعبه من
اجل ايقاف الحرب علينا ان لا ننسى ايضا ان
الناس قد اضطروا الى النزوح وانتقلوا الى
دول اخرى الى اثيوبيا ودول اخرى ما
اعتقد انه سيحدث انه هنالك التزام اكبر من
دول الجوار لكي تلعب دورا مهما في التوصل
الى حل لان الوضع قد تصعد
وثانيا ان الوضع في السودان
يطغى عليه الطابع القبلي الان وهذا امر
مدمر للسودان وايضا اقول ان قوه حفظ
السلام
تتكون وليس فقط من جنود دول الجوار فقط
لكن قوه حفظ السلام بين جنود من اطراف
اخرى من افريقيا الذين ليسوا على صله
مباشره معتقد انهم سيحرزونه فرقا من
السنغال ونيجيريا وجنوب افريقيا ومن دول
افريقيه اخرى اما المغرب وتونس
واجزاء اخرى من القرن الافريقي ايضا لكن
سيد بروك هايل يعني هل الدول الافريقيه
موقفها موحد فيما يتعلق بما يجري في
السودان
نعم سؤال وجيه اخر معظمهم هم لديهم موقف
ومتشابه قد
معظمه معظم دول الجوار كذلك لكن هنالك دول
تدعم الجنرتي وبعضها تدعم الجنرال البرهان
لكن هنالك شيء مشترك انهم يدعمون نهايه
هذا القتال مساله قوات حفظ السلام التي
تتتكون من جنود ليجاد والامم المتحده
والاتحاد الافريقي هو ان لا يتم فقط نشر
الجنود الذين ياتمون من دول الجوار ومثل
اذا ما قمنا بتفادي هذا العنصر اذا ما اتت
القوات من خارج حتى من خارج افريقيا ربما
من وسطي وشمال افريقيا التي ليس لديها صله
جغرافيه مباشره مع السودان اعتقد ان نسبه
نجاح عمل هذه القوه ستكون اكبر سيد حافظ
كبير ما تقييمكم للجهود التي يقوم بها
الاتحاد الا فريقي ومنظمه الايجاد
وبالطبع هذه الجهود جهود مقدره هناك
زيارات قامت بها الاطراف حتى
لرؤساء هذه الدول
وتم شرح الموقف
لدول الجوار وكذلك دول الايجارات وهي دول
مهمه جدا بالنسبه للسودان وبالنسبه
للاوضاع السياسيه داخل السودان تتاثر هي
كذلك بما يجري في السودان لكن اعتقد ان
التركيز الجهود كلها في دول افريقيا او في
الدول الايجارات بالنسبه للجيش هو هروب من
استحقاق اساسي جدا وهو الظن بان بانه يمكن
تحقيق مكاسب غير غير تلك المكاسب التي
يمكن تحقيقها من خلال المبادره السعوديه
الامريكيه التي تركز بالاسات على التحول
الديمقراطي هناك يعني
اعتقاد قديم لدى النظام بانه من خلال
افريقيا يمكن ان يؤثر اكثر يمكن ان يحقق
مكاتب اكثر باعتبار ان السودان عضوا في
هذه المنظمه وانه وان هذه الدول لا تتدخل
كثيرا ولا ليس لديها كره الضغط على
السودان
لم اسمع سؤال جيدا سيد حافظ كنت اشرت الى
موقف للجيش في بدايه الجزء الاول من
السؤال
اذا الصوت واضح اتفضل لانه الصوت يتقدح
تفضل
الجيش كان في البدايه يعني يظن بانه قادر
على حسم هذه المعركه عسكرين وبالتالي رفض
كثير من المبادرات لكنه الان يبحث عن مخرج
ويريد يريد هذا المخرج عبر الدول
الافريقيه التي كما اشرته لا تستطيع الضغط
عليه كثيرا لكن هذا ايضا هذا مفهوم خاطئ
الاتحاد الافريقي نفسه علق عضويه السودان
عندما حدث انقلاب عسكري في 25 من اكتوبر
وكذلك هناك يعني اتجاه عام رافض للحرب
وبالتالي هذا يتعارض ايضا مع رؤيه الجيش
التي تعتمد بالاساس على حسم المعرفه
عسكريا وهو لا يستطيع فعل ذلك من خلال
التجربه من خلال الواقع الميدان لكن اعتقد
ان الدعم السريع يوافق على
اي مبادره تصب في مصلحه اجنده محدده وهي
اجنده يعني عوده النظام البائد او عدم
سيطرته على الجيش وكذلك التحول هذه اجنده
واضحه ومعلومه وهذا التفاوض ينقسم الى
مرحلتين المرحله الاولى مرحله عسكريه يتم
من خلالها من خلالها وقف اطلاق النار هناك
مرحله اخرى سياسيه تشترك فيها اطراف اخرى
غير حتى القوات المسلحه والدعم السريع وهي
هذه لديها تصور
من خلال الاتفاق الايطالي وكذلك لديها
تصور للاصلاح الامني والعسكري سيكون حاضرا
في اي مبادره سواء كان هذه المبادره
الامريكيه او حتى
مبادره الايجارات وبالتالي هذه الاجنده
يعني متى ما تحققت متى ما وجد من يمكن
مناقشته من خلالها ليس هناك مانع لكن
اعتقد ان الاساءه التركيز على الدول
الافريقيه هو هروب من الضغوط او العقوب
حافظ كبير لديه دقيقه سيد احمد عمر خوجلي
السؤال لو سمحتي لم اسمع يعني ان الجيش
يمكن ان يكون اقرب الى مبادره من الاتحاد
الافريقي لان قدرته على التاثير قد تكون
اعلى خاصه فيما يتعلق بما يدعيه الدعم
السريع ان الجيش لا يريد التحول
الديمقراطي
المبادره كما ذكرت لكم مبادره الاتحاد
الافريقي هي اقرب الى روحه السودان ولا
ظروفه المحيطه ولكن
الجيش السوداني لغه المسلحه السودانيه
يعني
باقل من 30 ثانيه في بدايه الامر
في البدايه
التعامل مع هذا الحادثه هذا بانه تمرد
لقوه تابعه له وسوف تحسم سريعا باعتبار
انه هذا تصرف محدود ولكن الطريقه التي
يحارب بها الدعم السريع والحيل والتمركز
داخل بيوت المواطنين عطلت من هذا الامر
اعترض من هذا الامر من حصه الجيش على
المواطنين وعالم التركات احمد عمر الكاتب
والمحلل للسياسي من ام درمان ومن الخرطوم
حافظ كبير الكاتب والمحلل السياسي ومن
اديس ابابا بروكا هايلو استاذ علوم
السياسيه والدراسات الافريقيه شكرا لكم
الى هنا تنتهي هذه الحلقه من برنامج ما
وراء الخبر الى اللقاء
[موسيقى]